Rob starts off this hour in Chicago hey
Rob welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
good afternoon Dave thanks for taking my
call
sure what's up in your world well I've
got a weird question for you certainly
my girlfriend and I are concerned we are
putting too much towards retirement and
was hoping to get some guidance on that
how can you put too much towards
retirement well run it running the
numbers we are contributing 60,000
annually in tax advantaged accounts and
my concern is that you know in 40 years
we're looking at that rate of return
conservatively a 5% I'm seeing 10
million dollars and that honestly seems
like just too much for two people you
know okay all right well I have a
different perspective on that I mean
obviously if that happened you would
have no trouble giving it away if you
needed to to maintain yourself certainly
I'm a I'm an evangelical Christian and
so my view my worldview is that I don't
own anything that I manage what I have
forgot and so in that case I'm called to
manage that for him which the first rule
would be to take care of my own
household that's long past if you have
ten million dollars the second rule
would be to take care of my retirement
and that the end of changed my family
tree you know to leave an inheritance to
my children and I'm long past that and
if you had ten million dollars you'd be
long past that and then the third goal
passed those things scripturally in that
order it is to obviously care for others
and use that money for good and the more
money you have the more good you can do
assuming you're managing it with that
mindset now if you're only mindset as
hedonism is consumption then I would
agree with you that you
need that much and it would be it could
be possibly even spiritually emotionally
dangerous to have money that much
becomes turned in on one's self but
that's not the you know that's not the
theology or the philosophy I lived my
life by absolutely I should clarify we
do give charitable a currently and plant
you for many years have you heard of the
charity unbound no it's actually one of
our favorites it's sponsoring children
and senior citizens internationally it's
associated with the Catholic Church cool
and right I love them because they
actually give 97 cents on a dollar
through the actual mission right which
you don't see with a lot of charities so
right
well that's because probably because
they're under written for their
administrative by the Catholic Church
which is awesome and so you know what
you know you're giving dollar is being
very efficiently used which the
efficiency of the giving dollar is very
very important but I mean what if you
could give ten million dollars to that
or what if you could do a million
dollars a year just off of the interest
that the 10 million creates you know or
or whatever what if you just walked up
and found a single mom we were
struggling and bought her a car I mean
you know what if you found I mean the
think of the things you can do like that
if you're not in wordly turned now if
you're only consuming it like a
four-year-old you're gonna be an unhappy
person because you know stuff does not
make you happy it's okay it gets you
some stuff stuffs not evil wealth is not
evil but but this idea that you chase
that in order to be happy is a really
dangerous thing spiritually and
emotionally I wouldn't do that
so to say I think it would be a
wonderful problem to have okay
do you recommend creating a legacy sort
of in terms of the state planning
absolutely absolutely having an
available giving and or do you know what
guys anticipate having children yes a
minimum of three okay fair that's
wonderful yeah and so then you start to
think about okay what you know what does
wealth do to children and so there are
there are a group of P
bullying there are stereotypes that
assume that if you had 10 or 20 million
or a hundred million that it would
destroy your children I have three very
high-functioning adult children and our
wealth has not destroyed them I have
grandchildren that will be the same
we've taught them to work they're in no
way entitled they have the same
worldview that we do and if they don't
share that worldview there'll be no
inheritance to them because I'm not
leaving money to them to do cocaine with
a rot around on a yacht they're there
they're there to do good in the world
and the wealth is a tool to do good in
the world and if that's how you see it
then you can raise children and not
damage them with wealth as well but you
could don't raise children that just
have a reality show otherwise right yes
have you have you looked into the giving
pledge personally maybe the the Buffett
and Gates deal yeah yeah yeah yes I
think it's over 90 percent of your your
assets you give away to charity at steps
on your death I think that's a mission
that's really appealing it is appealing
but it again makes the assumption that
your kids are going to mismanage the
money and the charity will manage it
better and I don't philosophically line
up with that assumption I'm okay if
that's what you want to do it's your
money I got no issue with it and
certainly I think but we don't want to
get into this idea because see what that
ties into if you believe that you must
do that in order to be spiritually and
emotionally whole then what you're
really saying is is that the money is
dirty the money is evil and the money's
really not it's people that are and so
if you left money to your child and it
hurts your child and then what parent
would do that and if you assume that a
hundred percent of the time that you do
that you damage your children no but I
am acquainted with and have studied
several wealthy families of faith faith
faith families that have handed the
money to the next generation and
continued generationally to do good
works yeah and I think that also is a
wonderful legacy so the idea that
somehow that a charity is going to
manage it better than a godly family not
necessarily true matter of fact there's
a lot of charities are mismanaged we
have a Family Foundation we
to study and do due diligence on them to
make sure that there's something like
you were talking about 97% efficiency
and not the other way around
not a flapper cent efficiency you know
so you can't assume that charities
aren't going to have a glitch as well or
our ministry's not going to have a
glitch as well there's money that is
mishandled in any type of organization
whether it be a family a church a
ministry a parachurch organization the
Vatican doesn't matter who they're
they're everywhere you go there's an
opportunity for money to be mishandled
misappropriated poorly managed stolen
because people are involved and so you
just can't get away from that idea so
it's a fun discussion though so no I
don't think you're saving too much if
you have the right worldview and mindset
with the money
hold on I'll send you a copy of a book I
did on this subject it's called the
legacy journey it is written from my
faith perspective fair warning but hold
on I'll send you a copy of it as a gift